please welcome shyla patterson
hi good afternoon everybody
it's an honor for me to be here and it's
a great privilege for me to be able to
greet all of you
and introduce our special guest um i'd
like to thank
all of the employers the community
leaders the students and of course
the elected officials who are here today
as part of this important event
briefly i'd like to talk about my story
what led me here today
if you guys have the time
so um academically i've always
enjoyed school and i've always done well
i was i worked hard throughout the
years and i was able to graduate early
at the age of 16 years old
it was a journey and being a young
graduate
there weren't a lot of employment
opportunities you can't get good jobs so
i was doing odd jobs like babysitting
typical teenage work
i was able to land my first job when i
was 18 years old
in the retail industry and i didn't feel
any passion for it until i was able to
come into the manufacturing industry
i got my first manufacturing job at a
place called king nut out in solon
and i was a simple line packer
but they had these giant machines that
bagged trail mix and
they fascinated me to no end they were
cnc
machines and i slowly but surely taught
myself to operate them until
my plant manager took notice and decided
that
i was he saw that i was capable
and had a natural affinity for these
machines and
the work that they do and he promoted me
to a machine operator
and i never looked back from there
manufacturing was my passion
and i strive to be the best there could
be
in the manufacturing industry
that's what led me to the ata my cousin
recommended the program she had
successfully completed it the year prior
and i was at 19 i became a single mother
and with the thought in my heart that i
wanted my daughter to see
and do better i joined the program i
contacted them
and it's been one of the best decisions
i've ever made
i made it through the program you
despite in the middle of the semester
the covet pandemic hit the world and
shut the school down
the program was very good at
contacting all the students keeping us
all retained
making sure we were able to finish
successfully and
even worked with us afterwards for job
placement
after that i was put into
the job at hose master working closely
with the ata staff until
you know the interview and
their contacts with hose master and the
the manufacturing connections that they
do have
are what creates these opportunities i'm
very grateful for that
i recently was promoted at my position
after all of the
i was put in as a fittings coordinator
i learned everything there is to know
about the
i'm sorry
i learned a lot at my new job at
postmaster i did a lot
of lateral moves branching out on my
machining
experience into administrative roles
where i was recently promoted into our
quality team
it's been a wonderful journey and i have
tri-c
and the ata program to thank for that
so in closing i would like to thank
president biden for his time and
attention
to an industry that's so important to me
manufacturing
means so much to me and for to get this
care and attention from him is
invaluable and the opportunity
that led me here today i'm ever grateful
for
so in closing i'd like to introduce and
welcome the 46th president of the united
states
joe biden
thank you all thank you
[Applause]
thank you
please please please please sit down
charlotte thank you very much for
sharing your story it's impressive
dr johnson everyone at cuyahoga
community college thank you for being
here and having me here
and by the way all the elected officials
you know we call this
in my business we call this a bustman's
holiday
you have to come and ride a bus again
with another guy you're awful nice to be
here
the only thing worse for an elected
official when the president shows up
is to say the worst sentence in english
language is
i'm at the airport and so
so thank you all so much you got some
really great friends here
start with marcy and anyway mr mayor
thank you
dr johnson thank you very much and uh
for letting
me borrow by the way uh uh marcia fudge
uh
to serve as a secretary of housing and
urban development
[Applause]
you know certain places just by chance
and circumstance can become
a markers in the course of your life or
nate of the course of the nation and for
me
tri-c is one of those places just a
little over a year ago
march 10 220 and 2020 i came to
cleveland as a candidate running for
president
to rally hold a rally here at the
community college
upon unloading we got word that governor
dewine
he did the right thing wanted large
indoor events
to shut down because of the growing
concerns over the virus
and spreading all across america there
would be no
rally that night and life in america
had changed and a long dark year
was about to descend upon all of us
14 months later we finally made it to
campus
from a year of darkness we're now
emerging into the light
and i said from the very beginning
there's no
chance no chance for this economy to
come back
unless we beat the pandemic i remember
congressman ryan and i talking about
that a lot in the campaign trail
you had to beat the pandemic to bring
the economy back
and so that's what we set out to do with
help a lot of the people that are right
here
and after administering 271 million
doses of vaccine in the first 120 days
and we have the cases are down now from
january from
they're down 83 covet cases down
the number of deaths has fallen by 85
schools reopening businesses are opening
restaurants are reopening and i hear
that uh
as last night's vaccine lottery ohio has
a new millionaire
i'll tell you what who would have thunk
it
a million bucks for getting the vaccine
but it's working now 56
of ohioans have had at least one shot
we got to get to 70 percent that's the
goal
we've turned the tide on the once in a
century pandemic
we've turned a tide on a once in a
generation economic crisis
and families are beginning to be able to
breathe just a little bit easier
we still have work to do but our future
today is as bright and as wide open as
it ever has been and now we're faced
with a question
what kind of economy are we going to
build for tomorrow
what are we going to do i believe
this is our moment to rebuild an economy
from the bottom up in the middle out
not a trickle-down economy from the very
wealthy
that has never benefited people who are
at this college
or any other place where they're trying
to make a living
to build an economy that rewards work
not just wealth
an economy that works for the backbone
of this country
the people who get up every single day
work hard
raise their families pay their taxes
serve their country volunteered
in their communities just looking for a
little bit of breathing room
my dad you said just a little bit of
breathing room honey
and tim has heard me say this a thousand
times my dad used to say joey at jobs
about a lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
it's about your place in the community
it's about being able to look your kid
in the eye and say
it's going to be okay the last
few months have demonstrated what that
economy
can look like when uh
when our event here was cancelled in
march our economy was on the brink of
collapse
my mom used to have a specialty say you
know the greatest gift god gave mankind
was the ability to forget
because we didn't do that everyone would
only have one child
um but all kidding aside the good news
is we forget the bad times that's the
good thing about we americans we're
always optimistic
but 10 months 10 months ago
we were in trouble when i was sworn in
there were 10 million fewer jobs in
america
and a lot here in ohio
but in my first three months in office
the economy has added back
500 000 jobs per month in fact
we've created with the help again of the
members of congress that are here today
1.5 million jobs more jobs than have
ever been created
in the first three months of any
presidency in the history of the united
states
before i took office the average initial
claims for unemployment insurance
were over 830 000
this morning we learned that number has
fallen below
460 000. we're going to have to
and we're at the lowest level we've seen
since march
2020 when the pandemic first struck
before i took office almost 24 million
americans were going hungry
marcy's heard me say this before did you
ever think you'd see
people lined up for miles and miles and
miles
going on the stadium to get someone to
put a box of food
in their trunk people never ever ever
ever
ever ever ever thought they need that
kind of help
well that number of hungry americans
food starved americans has dropped by 30
percent
still too many but there's clear
progress
before i took office independent experts
were projecting that our economy would
grow
at three to four percent in the year
2021
but they're now projecting that growth
will be six percent
or higher than 2021
the fastest growth in this country in 40
years
to sum it up covert cases are down
covert deaths are down unemployment
filings are down
hunger is down vaccinations are up jobs
are up growth is up
people gaining health coverage is up
small business confidence is up
put it simply america's coming back
america is on the move
[Applause]
and that wasn't an accident it wasn't
luck
it happened for two reasons first
we made the vaccine program a priority
as my friends in congress i got a lot of
heat for just focusing on the vaccine
goes back to what we all talk about
you've got to
fix the pandemic before you can fix the
economy
we were able a lot of hard work at 600
million dose of the vaccine enough for
every
single solitary american we didn't have
enough vaccinators
so it went to fema the united states
military
went to the ama and got retired docs and
nurses to come out of
retirement got thousands and thousands
of additional people to administer the
vaccines that we didn't have before
we created more places to get vaccinated
hitting my target to ensure that 90 of
all americans
would have a vaccination site within 5
miles of where they live
and now 50 of all of america
more than any other country is fully
vaccinated
75 75
of seniors black white hispanic across
the board are
fully vaccinated we're getting lives
back
american economy is coming back and
that's the second reason we're on the
move
i committed to an approach of building
an american economy a re a different
economy to build back
better not just build back go back
better
that approach recognizes that we do all
do better
we all do well and the best way
to grow our economy is from the bottom
up and the middle out
you know i don't have anything against
against anybody in wall street i don't
think against anybody making a million
bucks but
wall street did not build this country
the middle class built this country
and unions built the middle class
that's a fact
[Applause]
an approach to recognize that this time
when we rebuild the middle class we have
to bring
everybody along regardless of their
background regardless of the religion
regardless of their race
that's the approach reflected in the
american rescue plan which my friends in
the congress
helped get past because of that law
more than 167 million
americans got a rescue payment of 1400
it's gone out helping families pay their
rent pay their bills
buy their groceries and maybe most
important give them for the first time
some hope
a little bit of hope hope goes a long
long long way those checks mattered
small businesses restaurants are getting
we're getting killed
now we're delivering the loans and
support they need to reopen and stay
open
schools were struggling to reopen so we
made
targeting teachers to get the vaccine as
a priority
we delivered schools much needed support
state and local governments and you know
mr mayor a lot of them had to
lay off their employees cops
firefighters first responders
because you have to balance your budget
well now they're coming back thanks to
the rescue plan
beginning this summer families with
children will get
tax relief tax credit the child tax
credit
which is going to deposit money directly
into their banks every month until that
money is paid out
by the way we had no problem passing a 2
trillion dollar
tax plan it went to the top one percent
that wasn't paid for it all just
increased the debt two trillion dollars
every time i talk about tax cuts for
working class people say oh my god
what are we going to do well we're going
to take back some of that one percent
money and make them pay for it
[Applause]
thanks in part to a part of the rescue
plan named for an ohio labor leader
butch lewis
championed by sherrod brown who i don't
think sheriff's here today
hundreds of thousands of retirees and
workers across
ohio and millions more across the
country can trust
that their pensions they work so damn
hard for
and sacrifice to secure will be there
for them
unlike my dad who busted his neck his
whole life and when the company went on
he lost his pension
completely even my republican friends in
congress
not a single one of them voted for the
rescue plan
i'm not going to embarrass any one of
them but i have
here a list
of how back in their districts they're
bragging about
the rescue plan they touted the
restaurant revitalization fund they
touted the fact that we're in a
situation where the
dealing with touted grants to community
health care centers
touted i mean
some people have no shame but i'm happy
i'm happy they know that it benefited
their constituents
that's okay with me but if you're going
to try to take credit
for what you've done don't get in the
way
of what we still need to do the bottom
line
[Applause]
the bottom line is this the biden
economic plan is working
we had record job creation we're seeing
record economic growth
we're creating a new paradigm one that
rewards work
the working people in this nation not
just those at the top
we did a study 85 percent of my jobs
plan
or 95 of adjustment you don't need a
bachelor's degree
75 you don't even need a degree
that's a community college degree it
helps
but guess what the bottom line is
that people are going to be going back
to work
there's a new bargain everyone is going
to be in on the deal this time
now as our economy recovers there's
going to be some bumps in the road we
know that of course there will be you
can't reboot a global economy like
flipping on a light switch
there's going to be ups and downs in
jobs and economic reports
there's going to be supply chain issues
price distortions on the way back to a
stable
and steady growth in the coming weeks my
administration will take steps to combat
these supply pressures starting with the
construction materials
and transportation bottlenecks and
building off the work
we're doing on computer chips we're also
announcing new initiatives combat
anti-competitive practices that hurt
small businesses and families
fixing those problems can help build
more dynamic innovative economy and
we're going to have a lot more to say
about that in the days ahead but this
this is already clear we're on the right
track
the american rescue plan laid a strong
foundation for a new economy that brings
everybody along
but it's just a first step we're going
to build on the incentive
and incredible progress that we've made
and set america on a sustainable path to
faster more inclusive economic growth
we have to start investing in ourselves
again and the american people again
consider this three decades ago
the united states was number one and
some would argue number two in the world
for r d
spending research and development is a
share of our economy
know we are now in the international
competition
number nine nine
meanwhile china was number eight and
their overall spending and research and
developments three decades ago is
they're now number two number two
this past year japan canada italy france
and the eu
have announced significant
infrastructure spending
china has announced that they're
increasing their research and
development spending dramatically
japan is making huge investments and
reducing carbon emissions and building
out the digital capacity there
the european union as well we're in a
race
to see who wins the 21st century now if
i could hold just for a second here
one of the things i found i'm you know
i'm supposedly
that always announced me in the past as
an expert in foreign policy
well let me tell you something economic
policy is harder than foreign policy
you know what the basis of foreign
policy is in our stature in the world
one thing our economic prowess
our economic prowess we
must be number one in the world
to lead the world in the 21st century
it's a simple proposition
[Applause]
and the starting gun has already gone
off we can't afford
to fall any further behind now's the
time
to build the foundation that we've laid
to make bold investments in our families
and our communities in our nation
we know from history that these kinds of
investments raise both the floor
and the ceiling over the economy
for everybody like when we brought
electricity to every household in the
country in 1930s
or we connected the country to the
interstate highway system in the 50s
they created millions of jobs good
paying jobs
they set the economy up to grow more
quickly and share
prosperity more broadly for decades to
come
those electrical poles and wires still
help power rural communities
80 years after they were built and it's
time now to rebuild
them a quarter of all the miles
of american travel on roads are an
interstate highway system
built 60 years ago 60 years after we
built it
these are generational investments
private sector does not make these kind
of investments
we've neglected that kind of public
investment for much too long
the pandemic exposed just how badly we
need to invest in the foundation of this
country
and the working people in this country
that's why i propose the american jobs
plan
in america's family plan the
generational investments we need today
to succeed for tomorrow
you know as my wife jill who's been a
teacher for a long time
she used to be about 10 years younger me
now she's 30 years younger than me
she is in every way god love her
she's the only first lady ever to work
full-time
full-time she teaches 15 credits at the
community college
15 credits she's a remarkable person
and she's out in missouri right now and
kansas doing other things
nothing to do with her job as a teacher
but my point is this
jill has a constant refrain joey
any nation that out educates us
is going to out-compete us it's a simple
proposition
you know think about this one of the
reasons
that caused us to move ahead so
significantly
as a world leader and economic leader in
the world
was in the late 1800s early 1900s we're
the first nation in the world to say
we're going to have 12 years of
free without any limitation free
education 12 years
now imagine if and the rest of the
world's caught up with this
and they've now passed us in many cases
imagine if we were sitting today
and say we're going to set up an
education system does anybody think
12 years of education is enough for us
to compete in the world
in the second quarter of the 21st
century i'm not joking just
just consciously think about that is it
enough
it's not and so i'm proposing four
additional years of education
two years of high quality pre-k for
three and four years old
not in day care in school
the studies show that if you do that
those children have
an opportunity of 56 better 56
better chance of going through all 12
years of school
and beyond without getting any trouble
no matter what the background or the
family they come from
no matter what on the front end those
two years
are important and then two years of free
community college free community
[Applause]
to better prepare our people to get
these good paying jobs in the future
jobs i saw
students training for throughout the
manufacturing technology center
you know we need to invest in
transportation infrastructure
drive anywhere and you can see why we're
rated
13th in the world in infrastructure the
united states america
is viewed to have the 13th best
infrastructure in the world
come on this united states of america
for god's sake
we need to invest in universal
high-speed internet more seamlessly
connect our businesses and their
customers
expand the possibilities of job
opportunities in
every home town in america no matter how
big or small
and by the way it's a hole for a second
think about this
how many of you men and women have
children who were
doing remote learning think of
all the children throughout the country
in inner cities and in rural areas it
had no internet connection
it's estimated that some of those kids
are going to be pushed although it's
only been one year
three years behind in their education
look investment in high growth
industries like clean energy
electric vehicles it's not just we want
to
deal with the environment we want to
lead the world and exports
of these new technologies instead of
seeding the global market
and job creation to the chinese
they're building 20 times as many
electric vehicles we're doing now
and the technology that goes with that
what are we doing
it's millions of jobs in china instead
of here it's not that the jobs we're
going to create here but
we're going to create to export the
technology we used to be the net
exporter
of major technologies i also think
and pushing very hard to make major
investments in medicines and cures of
the future
folks diseases like alzheimer's diabetes
cancers
they're all on the cusp of being able to
be dealt with
you know if we don't do something about
alzheimer's in america
every single solitary hospital bed that
exists in america the nurses can tell
you
every single one will be occupied the
next 15 years in an alzheimer's patient
every one costing us in excess of a
trillion dollars
so what are we doing i came up with an
idea and i think is going to get done
and that is that you know there's a
thing called darpa which is a defense
applied application research it's an
outfit that came up with the internet
in the defense department came up with
geo spacing and
a whole range of things that are related
to our security
i want to do the same thing at the nih
to focus on those diseases it's
estimated if we reduce but we spend five
billion dollars a year
on that research and development
focusing with insurance companies
can't donate the money to focus on we
can make significant breakthroughs
we're already doing that already doing
that
if we invest we can create millions of
jobs
rebuilding the foundation of a strong
fair resilient competitive economy
and save hundreds of thousands of lives
one hundred percent of our investment is
going to be guided by one principle
make it in america
i can hold that for just a second there
is a law
that was passed in the 30s doesn't
violate any trade principle
saying that whatever money that whatever
program that taxpayers
are paying for you can spend it all
on american contractors
no one's ever done it i promise you i
signed an executive order
if in fact we're building the new deck
of an aircraft carrier
well guess what i get as president to
make let contracts over 600 billion
dollars a year
i promise you there'll be no contract
led
to a foreign company or
any of the product down the line right
now what can happen is
you can hire an american company and
they can sublet
and they can their downstream product
can all be foreign
all you got to do is get that particular
agency to say you got an exception we
can't find
that job here in america well guess what
they're going to find the job here in
america i promise you
or they're not going to get the
contracts these jobs will be good jobs
american jobs that deliver
good wages and dignity and look
this is a choice we've been giving we
keep doing every break
in the world to corporations ceos or we
can raise the corporate tax rate
back to 28 it was by the way
36 it came down to 28
which is still lower than it was at any
point between world war one
two 2017 and they're making trillions of
dollars
let me tell you this to the press again
in the 10-year period
between 14 and 24 excuse me between
uh 10 and 20 20 10 20 20.
they made over a trillion dollars i
think that's good
you know what they did with a trillion
dollars they went out and they bought
back
56 percent of their stock
because the more they buy back the more
valuable the stock
and that's how ceos get paid ceos used
to get paid
35 36 times to the average employee and
they should get paid
now it's over 370 times more than the
average employee
as my mother would say who died and left
them boss
so i'm serious about it now so you got
over 50 percent
going to stock buybacks and the other
percent
i think it's 42 percent uh you get let
me see 56
it's 40 uh no it's 38
goes to um dividends which is reasonable
but here's the point after all is said
and done that leaves eight percent of
that trillion dollars
for research and development salaries
new product new enterprises
new initiatives 80
i come from the corporate capital of the
world
literally more corporations are
incorporating the state of dollar than
any place in america combined
all the rest of the corporate
registrations combined don't equal to my
state
it used to be corporations felt they had
responsibilities
beyond their taxpayer and be beyond
their shareholders
and beyond their executives
but what is it now average ceo
becomes a ceo for six to seven years
and by the way capitalism has incentives
one of the worst votes ever made was
during the carter the clinton
administration
say a corporation could not deduct and
tack
the duck from their taxes more than a
million dollars have paid for any ceo
so guess what they start doing 80 some
percent of ceos now get paid in stock
options
why do you think they buy back the stock
to raise the price individually
other stock they're not bad guys
it's just the incentives so if we just
raise the corporate tax to 28
which is still lower than where it was i
said between world war
1 and 2017 that generates 90 billion
additional dollars into the treasury for
a year
per year that could put hundreds of
thousands of people to work
to modernize our roads our bridges our
ports our airports
and pay for it pay
for it
[Applause]
put people to work to make sure every
american has access to high-speed
internet
so businesses can compete in the 21st
century kids in every community can get
ahead
another choice we can ask the top one
percent of the taxpayers in america
to get paid the same tax rate they paid
when george w
bush was president you know how much
that would generate
that generated 13 billion dollars per
year
allowing every student in america to go
to community college for free
when i was in the last administration
that i was part of
obama biden president asked me to find
out what the
major corporate entities thought was the
most important thing they needed
we interviewed over 340 i think is 348
ceos you know what they said every one
of them a better educated workforce
but they're not spending money to
educate the workforce
so imagine what we do corporate america
with a better educated population
do you want to give the wealthiest
people in america another tax cut i
don't i don't
begrudge them the money they made just
start paying your fair share just a
little bit
consequence would help every high school
graduate earn an education like
students here at tri-c one that puts
people on a path to good paying jobs and
industries of the future look
i know i know you know what's best for
america
and by the way better educated public
helps
everybody look my plan is
my plan is the right way to invest
spreading key investments over time
so we limit the price pressure this is
the right time to invest when we have
historically low interest rates
investing now with a plan to pay for it
that is fiscally responsible thing to do
of course there are critics out there
who want to stand still
by the way some of those critics are the
same people who said that money was no
object
when it came as i said to that two
trillion dollar tax cut
that went to the wealthiest one percent
of america who hold
30 percent of all the wealth in the
country but when we need to fix a road
or a water system
or help millions of people return to the
workforce by helping them afford child
care
or elder care or help afford attend the
ability to
attend tri-c they think that's
that's a bridge too far
investing in america again is going to
create growth more jobs
but there's something else we have to do
to ensure the high quality jobs
exist we must restore the connection
between the success of our economy
and the people who produce that success
hard-working americans
the connection has been severed you all
remember it used to be the case in this
country when you were part of
generating success of a company you got
to share in the benefits
that's long since gone not a joke and by
the way
i i i'm a capitalist
but here's the deal from 1948 after the
war
to 1977 i think it was 1977
79 productivity in america grew by
100 we made more things
productivity you know what the workers
pay group
by 100
since 1979 all that changed product
productivity has grown
four times faster than pay has grown
the basic bargain in this country has
been broken if you work hard and
contribute to the success of enterprise
you get to share
success that's not the case anymore
so you can carve out your place in the
middle class
that's how it happens that's how it
works in healthy capitalist economies
but along the way
we started seeing the stock market and
corporate profits and executive pay
as the sole measure of our economic
success
let me tell you something my sole
measure of economic success how working
families are doing whether they have
jobs that deliver dignity
that means we have to focus on wages
like we used to
when it comes to the economy we're
building rising wages
aren't a bug they're a feature we want
to get
we want to get something economists call
full employment
instead of workers competing with each
other for jobs that are scarce
we want employers to compete with each
other to attract work we want
the companies to compete to attract
workers
that kind of competition in the market
doesn't just give workers more ability
to earn a higher wage gives them the
power to demand to be treated with
dignity and respect in the workplace
it helps ensure that america when you
walk into work you don't have to
check your right to be treated with
respect at the door
full employment also means more options
and opportunities for workers including
black hispanic workers ameri asian
american workers women
who've been left behind in previous
economic recoveries
when the labor market never tightened up
enough
look this isn't just good for individual
workers
it also makes our economy a whole lot
stronger
when american workers have more money to
spend american businesses benefit
we all benefit higher wages and more
options for workers are a good thing
a lot of companies have done extremely
well in this crisis and good for them
good for them the simple fact is though
corporate profits are the highest
they've been in decades
and workers pay is that the lowest has
been in 70 years
we have more than ample room to raise
workers pays without raising customer
prices
soaring corporate profits and stagnant
wages aren't the american dream
and they aren't the american deal look
i'm not looking to punish anyone i'm
gonna say business shouldn't be able to
make a significant profit i understand
the risks and challenges
business owners face and they should be
rewarded for their success and the risk
they take
i just think after decades of workers
getting the raw deal it's time to be
given a fair
shake
we're already seeing what happens when
employers have to compete for workers
companies like mcdonald's home depot
bank of america and others
what do they have to do they have to
raise wages
to attract workers that's the way it's
supposed to be
and we've got to do two more things
congress should raise the minimum wage
to 15 an hour
no one no one should work 40 hours a
week
and live in poverty live below the
poverty level
and we ought to pass to protect the
right to organize the pro-act supported
by union workers
look let me close with this
[Applause]
you know it's an overused phrase these
days but it's still
accurate we're at an inflection point in
american history
it happens every several generations
we have a chance to seize the economic
momentum
of the first months of my administration
not just to build back
but to build that better and this time
we're going to deal everyone in
everyone has been left out and breathe
new life into the middle class
a new hope into those struggling to
break into the middle class
we have a chance to make investments
that moody's not a liberal think tank
wall street moody's says my plan
will increase the size of our economy by
4.5 trillion dollars
moody's 4.5 trillion dollars over the
next decade
and create well over 16 million new good
paying jobs
if we make these investments now in 50
years
people will look back not even that long
your children or grandchildren look back
say this was the moment when america won
the future
won the future folks
you've said it a thousand times and made
it from the bottom of my heart
there's not a single thing america can't
do
when we do it together never we're the
only country in the world
is when we set our mind at something
that never ever
ever failed this is an opportunity
for the wealthy to stay wealthy the poor
to have a shot in the middle class in
the middle class
able to breathe more easily that's what
this is about but this time
bring everybody along everybody
thank you god bless you and may god
protect our troops
[Applause]
you